von ewigen Chemikalien zur ewigen
Verdammnis mit anderen Worten kommen wir
zur katholischen Kirche die hat gerade
in Frankfurt beim Synodalen Weg nach
über drei Jahren Debatte Reform
beschlossen ja
also eine konkretere Form homosexuelle
Paare können sogar in der Kirche
gesegnet werden wenn sich ein einzelner
Bischof findet der das erlaubt und
mitmacht dazu muss man wissen die
katholische Kirche hat sogar mal dieses
Absperrgitter vor dem Kölner Dom
gesegnet aber das war halt auch nicht
schwul
komm der Synodale Weg ist ja nur der
erste Schritt zum Synodalen Rat einem
permanenten Gremium wo Kleriker und
Laien gemeinsam entscheiden würden wie
kommt diese an die Idee im Vatikan laute
Antwort aus Rom müssen die Bischöfe kein
Entscheidungsgremium aus Klerus und
Gläubigen mitbegründen dass die
bischöfliche macht erstmals verbindlich
beschneiden würde Gott sei Dank Gott sei
Dank ich hatte mir so Sorgen gemacht um
die bischöfliche macht meine Damen und
Herren und ernsthaft warum soll man die
auch beschneiden hat sich doch total
bewährt so wie es ist zum Beispiel beim
Umgang mit dem Missbrauch Skandal das
mit der Macht war der eigentliche Grund
für den ganzen Synodalen Weg deshalb ist
die Stimmung bei vielen engagierten
leihen jetzt auch eher so ja heiter bis
Wolky sagen wir mal ne
übrigens deshalb hat der Papst damals
seinen Rücktritt gesucht abgelehnt nicht
angenommen Rainer Maria wird noch
gebraucht als Bollwerk gegen Reformer
wie geht's ihm selber so dabei zum
gespürt bin ich geworden den ganzen Tag
ein jeder verhöhnt mich
gut mit den Klamotten
Woki und Co haben in Frankfurt zwar
nicht Wasser zu weinen aber Forderungen
nach Reform in Prüfaufträge verwandelt
man bittet zum Beispiel den Papst den
Pflicht Zölibat noch einmal zu prüfen
mit dabei war auch wölkis Weihbischof
Ansgar Puff dem Entschuldigung Kinder
dem hatte das Kölner
missbrauchsgutachten Pflichtverletzung
vorgeworfen weshalb der Herr Puff sich
neulich noch eine Auszeit nehmen musste
wissen sie so jetzt
ist er trotzdem voll stimmberechtigt
beim Synodalen weg ist dann also machst
du nichts ich hätte wirklich auch nur
eine winzige bitte an den Ansgar
vielleicht mal ein bisschen weniger
reden über das eine
weibischof Ansgar Puff redet ohne Not
ständig übers knattern ich will Spaß und
du willst Spaß wenn man zum Beispiel
miteinander schläft in anderen als
Objekt als Sexobjekt benutzt bis zum
Geschlechtsverkehr nach einem
One-Night-Stand in Form von miteinander
schlafen miteinander schlafen der
Begierde nachgeben so hat Johannes Paul
II mal gesagt ist wie aus dem Mülleimer
essen
[Applaus]
was für eine wunderbare Metapher meine
Damen und Herren so vier große
reformthemen hat der Synodale Weg
eigentlich nur vier Themen Umgang mit
Macht läuft wie gesagt super
Sexualmoral gerade gehört dann
chilliarts bitte um Prüfauftrag und
natürlich jetzt kommt die Rolle der Frau
dürfen Frauen vielleicht doch mal mehr
machen als Plätzchen backen fürs
Gemeindefest ja leider nein leider gar
nicht sagt rum ne Sachgrund Frauen die
Taufen oder die Beichte abnehmen das
geht nicht weil Johannes Paul der zweite
Mal gesagt hat das geht nicht und dann
geht das nicht Ende
engagierte Frauen die Schwester
philipperat haben deshalb so langsam den
Kaffee auf es wird die Zeit kommen dass
keine Priester mehr da sind und allzu
fern ist die glaube ich ja auch nicht
mehr danke
genau genau wie ihr hätte sie gerne laut
gejubelt aber das hat der Papst verboten
tatsächlich wurden bei uns im letzten
Jahr in Deutschland nur noch 33 Priester
geweiht im ganzen Jahr und da sie sich
ja nicht vermehren
wenigstens hat der Synodale Weg
beschlossen sich in Rom für die
Möglichkeit des Diakonats einzusetzen
von Frauen das ist die unterste weistufe
und exakt das was die Würzburger sinode
schon 1976 erfolglos gefordert hat sie
haben richtig gehört vor 47 Jahren wie
ein Ausschnitt aus der heute-show von
damals
so wir halten fest und das ist meine
persönliche Prognose Atomkraft ist also
die saubere Energie für die nächsten
Jahrhunderte jetzt aber man ganz anderes
Thema meine Damen und Herren die
Deutsche Bischofskonferenz bitte den
Papst zu prüfen ob vielleicht auch
Frauen zu diakonien geweiht werden
dürfen ja genau warum ich gleich ein
bisschen
mal so er wird Kanzler Schmidt
Nichtraucher
was wollen die Mädels als nächstes
Kanzlerin werden
ja merke gerade ich muss mir dringend
die Haare wieder mehr nach vorne kämpfen
ja so wie gerade gehört Klang Feminismus
in den 70ern war eine andere Zeit jetzt
aber mal ernsthaft hut ab für all die
Frauen die trotz der Rückschläge immer
noch an Reformen in ihrem Laden Glauben
soweit gehört die deutschen Katholiken
sind mit ihren Reformideen in der
Weltkirche eine kleine Minderheit sehen
wir uns doch mal so der katholische
Markenkern ist weit über 1000 Jahre alt
warum denn jetzt schon ändern nichts
Anbietern beim Zeitgeist offensiver
Macho Kult stell dich der Challenge
du bist jung irgendwie konservativ und
Besitzer eines Penis dich nervt die
ganze Vogue scheiße hier und Frauen die
alles dürfen was du darfst ganz genau
ganz genau dann mach jetzt den
ultimativen bad ass
[Musik]
15 Semester katholische Theologie ließ
Hebräisch Latein die Schriften von Tubus
von Aquin mehr Hardcore geht nicht wir
machen dich zum Alpha Babo sagt mir mal
einen coolen Verein wo nur Bros die gute
tragen und die Chicks plus schmückendes
Beiwerk sind ja okay die Hells Angels
aber sonst nur bei uns kriegt jeder
Bruder eine eigene Shisha die geile
Taste schockier deine Eltern und wird
katholischer Priester kommt zum Altar
Alter gott will dass du cool wirst
[Applaus]
ja das ist jetzt die entscheidende Frage
der ganze Synodale weg also wirklich nur
viel Weihrauch um nichts doch nur
angetäuschte Reform vorgetäuschte
Demokratie muss ganz ehrlich sagen das
wäre mir ein bisschen zu hart formuliert
sagen wir also lieber das dass wir in
der Schlussrunde noch viel Sinn
oderalität lernen müssen und der Heilige
Geist noch einiges zu tun hat
wo wenn wieder nichts passiert ist der
Geist Schuld voll praktisch Beschwerden
bitte ausschließlich an heiliger Geist
at huibu.de
doch liebe Gemeinde es geschehen noch
Zeichen und Wunder eine bayerische
Staatsanwaltschaft hat gerade die Büros
des Erzbistums München durchsucht wegen
Ermittlungen in einem Missbrauchsfall es
gab es noch nie erstmals greift der
Staat so ein ja als würden Gesetze auch
für die Kirche gelten können sich das
vorstellen sind das die ersten
vorsichtigen Schritte auf dem Weg zu
einem weltlichen Land Friedemann Weise
meint jetzt bloß nicht nachlassen
Ratschläge in die Fresse mit Friedemann
Weise
seit letztem Jahr sind erstmals weniger
als die Hälfte der Menschen in
Deutschland überhaupt noch in der Kirche
es gibt mittlerweile mehr payback-kunden
als Katholiken oder Evangelen kein Witz
Punkte statt Kreuze ist ja auch
verständlich bei Payback gibt es die
Prämie sofort du musst nicht warten bis
du den Löffel abgibst im Gegenteil für
200 Punkte kriegst du ein ganzes Löffel
Set sogar unsere drei apokalyptischen
Reiter Habeck Lindner und Scholz sind
nicht in der Kirche allerdings aus
verschiedenen Gründen Lindner ist klar
um Steuern zu sparen Scholz kann sich
nicht erinnern und Habeck weil er es
nicht erträgt dass Jesus cooler ist als
er sogar innerhalb der Kirchen gibt es
Verständnis für die Austritte wenn Jesus
heute leben würde wäre der erste der
austreten wird
klar würde Jesus austreten also wenn ein
Termin kriegt
warum wäre der überhaupt in Deutschland
wahrscheinlich übers Mittelmeer gekommen
egal Fachkräfte können wir immer
gebrauchen die Frage ist doch warum hat
die Kirche immer noch so viel
Sonderrechte warum gilt immer noch
kirchliches Arbeitsrecht in Kitas und
Krankenhäusern die komplett vom Staat
finanziert werden und warum treibt der
Staat für die Kirchen die Kirchensteuer
ein sogar der öffentliche Rundfunk muss
sich um die Zwangsgebühren für welches
Privatjets selbst kümmern und sogar wenn
du aus der Kirche austrittst weil du den
Laden nicht unterstützen willst
unterstützt du ihn trotzdem denn die
Kirche kriegt nicht nur die
Kirchensteuer sondern auch noch 600
Millionen im Jahr aus der Staatskasse
und top warum eigentlich der Grund vor
über 200 Jahren nach Napoleons Feldzügen
durch Europa mussten die Kirchen
Besitztümer an weltliche Fürsten
abtreten der Wald vor über 200 Jahren
ein kleiner Franzose mit lafontan
Komplex in Europa gewütet hat lassen wir
heute noch Reparationszahlungen wir
müssen endlich raus aus dem Deal das
steht übrigens schon seit 1949 im
Grundgesetz aber passiert ist bisher
nichts wie wir das mal umgekehrt mit
einer Entschädigung für das was die
Kirche die Gesellschaft gekostet hat was
ist mit der CO2-Bilanz der
Hexenverbrennung dem Imageschaden durch
die Kreuzzüge oder den zig Milliarden
die der deutschen Wirtschaft durch
kirchliche Feiertage entgangen sind
jeder schnöde Karfreitag kostet uns 3,5
Milliarden rechne das mal auf 200 Jahre
hoch und dann sprechen wir wieder ich
verstehe das nicht die haben doch so
viel Geld die Kirchen in Deutschland
sind alles andere als arm zusammen
besitzen sie ein geschätztes Vermögen
von mehr als 100 Milliarden Euro manche
Experten gehen von deutlich höheren
Zahlen aus unter anderem weil die
Immobilienwerte oft sagen wir mal
abgerundet werden der Kölner Dom steht
z.B mit symbolischen 27 Euro in der
Bilanz wirklich
na gut viel mehr ist ja wahrscheinlich
auch nicht wert Stichwort
Energieeffizienz ich sage nur einfach
Verglasung eigentlich müsstest du das
komplette Ding erstmal von außen dämmen
sind auch scheiße aus mein Ratschlag am
besten ihr zieht einfach um die Kaufhof
Filiale wird bestimmt bald frei da könnt
ihr dann die Umkleidekabinen als
Beispiel verwenden tschüss
[Musik]
Ratschläge in die Fresse mit Friedemann
Basel
hallo leute wenn ihr jetzt auf Gefällt
mir drückt und den Kanal abonniert zeige
ich euch meinen lautesten Schrei für das
menschliche Gehör ist der zwar nicht
wahrzunehmen aber ich würde eure Hunde
kurz rausbringen okay fertig